regardez bien ceci est pourtant une
plage celle de sainte anne la palud dans
le finistère une plage transformé par
les vacanciers en un vaste parking
nous avons vu trois mille véhicules
venir à 6 approprié l'espace
généralement réservé ailleurs aux jeux
de plage ou aux baigneurs
le moment on n'a aucune solution étant
donné qu'on n'a pas de nos moyens sont
pas suffisantes pour les voitures il ya
déjà les routes réservées limité à la
vitesse et tous ils envahissent les
plages on n'a qu'à leur donner les
plages et puis garder les routes pour
nous soumettre à bronzer
certains trouvent une facilité justement
se déplacer la voiture sur la plage et
d'impossibilité pour déshabiller pour
piquer un peu tous ces pratiques avaient
les enfants tu responsable du design aux
affaires c'est un point de repère à les
voitures c'est un point de repère les
gens disent tiens on a garé une voiture
leur est servie est clair c'est toujours
mieux d'avoir accidents mais les
accidents graf
j'en ai pas eu heureusement
mettons les craintes se joue entre d été
on ça mène ici moi c'est ce que je fais
on vient ici bonbons s'arrête ça va ce
qu'ils font du rodéo ça devient japy
critique